as russia's war on ukraine reached its
112th day
ukraine's plea for help from other
countries got a welcome boost
the leaders of three key european
countries took an overnight train to
ukraine their first visit here since the
war began french president emmanuel
macron german chancellor olaf schultz
and italian prime minister mario draghi
meeting with ukraine's leadership and
getting a tour of burpine a half hour
west of the capital the war has started
not on the 24th of february the war has
started from 2014. this is a city where
70 of all buildings have been destroyed
by russian shelling
macron telling reporters massacres were
carried out we have the first signs of
war crimes the german chancellor
described what he called the brutality
of the russian war of aggression
the destruction this war is causing he
said is terrible the leaders came here
for more than just a tour though after a
meeting with ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky macron promised to
provide six more caesar long-range guns
to ukraine as a group the leaders all
said they support granting ukraine's
status in the european union immediately
a move that could make it easier to get
more support from neighboring countries
soon and a decision on eu status is
right around the corner the eu meets a
week from now to decide whether ukraine
will be accepted possibly with some
conditions and president zielinski has
been invited to attend the g7 summit
which begins june 26th but he won't be
leaving ukraine he'll be joining by
video link pharah
sean o'shea reporting thank you sean